darnoc yeah welcome to this video I'm
playing vlok here we lock on located in
Saudi Arabia he actually challenged me
to to a normal blitz game this is not
within the five minute pool so no rating
has not miraculously climbed about 300
points it's just another rating system
within ICC and we have a ratty opening
and probably I'm transposing to a kettle
on the fire yeah if i play default so
this is the the challenge system where
you just challenge another player to a
game and it's not an auto pairing okay
played b5 and i exchanged i hope that
after Bishop f4 and a bishop trade that
the dark squares will be an issue for
black
b5 is some sometimes a viable idea
especially if you manage to go before
Bishop a six and you don't have any
immediate problems with the dark squares
and the C file net takes lots of time
here okay i know i'm actually am able to
exchange myself John okay I really don't
mind him to take on there for the pawn
on f4 only helps to control on the dark
squares at the center so on I don't I
don't mind the the double pole now night
be 32 c 5 this is one of the possible
ideas
one issue with this configuration of the
two bishops is if he doesn't take he's
not able to play Knight to d7 I mean he
really wants yeah oh yeah or here
sometimes the night is not bad on a six
carat I want to go to c5 on or a five
anyway so no use and spending lots of
time can huh
yeah I'm not so sure what what this is
doing not only for ya probably currency
fire efforts might be there diem okay
going to d three years am a good plan
anyway and the night only five also um
has the IDM to maybe go to this have no
vehicles queen bee six for example which
is the typical kind of move to to
connect rocks then I have not easily i
want to go here anyway enroute to see
five yes
yeah do I want to take on your form this
is a good question probably i don't want
to take the question is what about f3 is
f3 a good move maybe maybe f3 and III
and tonight as i want i want to go to
see five of the same
and I need to I need to do it now we've
got b7 e6 attacked and he cannot go
night somewhere because it's six hangs
and b-cell legs he needs to take and
then I every capture with with the night
my idea then is III 20 20 is really able
to play that move yeah why not why not
okay
a nice move a nice maneuver would be to
go to a 5 somehow but he's got our wait
I have an idea an entirely different
idea Bishop h3 is this sir this is a
possibility Bishop to h3 but I is gone
tonight to f5 come on I'm flying I'm
simply spending too much time for rather
unnecessary stuff I mean this kind of
position is just somewhat better for
white and I'm spending too much time to
figure out if I've got something even
better or something more precise if he
goes night f5 I play Queen d3 intending
III boats during the center and
attacking b5 puzzle difficult f5 yeah
now I'm this is this of course very nice
for me so III yell need to need to cover
all this and I need to reroute the
knight to e5 now
yeah ifb 3v3 coming
3h for I go h3 it's not not very nice
looking but so I'm probably all right
yeah I didn't play this perfectly this
much is clear then bishop on g2 is not
great I mean it's arguable if this is
even a better piece than be seven maybe
it is because I can go to d 3 at the
latest stage but he's got this Queen age
four and and stuff I don't know h3 is
really ugly okay I'm glad that that I'm
able to exchange some some stuff should
I take yeah man you take and here or to
e5 I don't know okay let's let's do this
tampering age form
Brooksie to want to go oxy 295 yeah his
son his son playing slowly here it's not
speeding up at all
twinbee to I want to exchange Queens
this is now on very advantageous for me
if I get Quinn self
ya know he must exchange oops okay I
really thought he needs to exchange time
morning and you should f1 black for fits
on time yeah I would the position now is
this really winning for what he he
really fought himself out of this and
okay I'm I helped somewhere around here
maybe maybe this wasn't so great after
all nike 53 I have a good position no
doubt about it but maybe I played this
the sub optimal fashion yeah thanks for
watching probably we've got the rematch